la policía y los médicos rodearon el
cuerpo de una persona que murió a causa
de disparos la noche del sábado en la
ciudad de portland el tiroteo ocurrió la
misma noche en que estallaron violentos
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes de
blacklight smarter y simpatizantes del
presidente de eeuu donald trump que
recorrieron el centro de portland en
cientos de vehículos un portavoz de la
policía dijo que era demasiado pronto
para relacionar la muerte del individuo
con los enfrentamientos y ya me cansé de
ver a gente racista venir a esta ciudad
y hacerme sentir intimidado y difundir
sus mentiras con sus banderas me hace
sentir realmente disgustado quiero
protestas pacíficas y no puedo decirle a
la gente cómo protestar pero al mismo
tiempo entiendo por qué todos los que
están en contra de trump están
protestando esta noche porque todos
estamos frustrados y aquí estamos ahora
hay un cadáver en el suelo
el periódico the new york times- lo
identificó como un hombre blanco que
vestía un sombrero con la insignia de
patchwork rey de un grupo de extrema
derecha con sede en portland aunque la
policía no ha revelado los detalles de
la víctima ni de los sospechosos del
tiroteo varias personas fueron
arrestadas durante los violentos
enfrentamientos del sábado por la noche
horas después chicago fue el escenario
de otro tiroteo dos policías resultaron
heridos luego de que intentarán detener
a una persona sospechosa de llevar un
arma el sujeto disparó contra los
agentes y un tercer policía acudió a la
escena e hirió al sospechoso la
situación se da justo en una tensa
semana de nuevas protestas contra la
brutalidad policial y el racismo
avivadas por la muerte de jake & blake
un hombre negro que recibió siete
disparos en la espalda por parte de un
oficial el pasado domingo en la ciudad
de que no sea en wisconsin